the NFL isn't concerned about you as a
fan the NFL was concerned about opening
up your pocketbook and pulling as much
money out of it as I possibly can
the NFL is the most lucrative sports
league in the world and many cities seem
desperate to have a football franchise
to call their own but no city is more
eager than Los Angeles the country's
second largest metropolis and football
desert since 1994 but does it make sense
to invest scarce public dollars on a
sports operation that boasts billions in
yearly profits and counts 18 of its
owners on the Forbes billionaire list in
general about 70% of the cost of
building and maintaining NFL stadium has
been paid for by taxpayers with city
budgets being pushed to the brink is it
time to demand that the NFL carry their
own financial weight there's a beauty to
the game I'd like to see the beauty in
Los Angeles I like what it does for a
city woman they feel good when their
team wins or well places like Los
Angeles continue to push for a costly
stadium built on the taxpayers dime the
NFL generated over 9 billion in revenues
last year and many cities are hungry for
a piece of the action often spending
huge sums of taxpayer dollars to attract
the league to their localities I say the
king of sports the NFL
good at two things providing high
quality sports entertainment against our
turret consistently terrific I'm hooked
and the NFL is good at fleecing
taxpayers it's about a billion dollars a
year I calculate public subsidies to NFL
owners and this is a group that consists
almost entirely of billionaires and yet
receiving significant public subsidies
every year nowhere is this Illustrated
more than in Los Angeles where the
city's political and investor class has
been trying for nearly two decades to
get a team back in the area and those
study after study has shown that sports
stadiums don't increase local economic
activity it hasn't stopped cash-strapped
cities like LA from approving
billion-dollar stadium plans that would
be largely funded with public dollars so
subsidizing a multi-billion dollar
organization worth the public cost City
Councilman Tom LaBonge thinks so and as
part of the effort to
during the NFL back to Los Angeles my
counter district has 274,000 220 people
more than Buffalo and just a little less
than Cincinnati so you could put a
council NFL in my district Lebon she
spent part of his early career with NFL
Films feels a personal stake in bringing
the NFL back to the city he loves each
season he writes the league and team
owners to make the case for football in
Los Angeles have a son is 15 and he's
never had a hometown team and I said you
know I want to just reach out it was a
simple reach out and got a couple of
responses it was good but someone from
the National Football League has to say
I want to be in Los Angeles I want to be
in the second-largest market in the
country but no one has does having a
generation of fans without a hometown
team justify spending loads of public
money on a stadium especially in a place
like Los Angeles which is chronically in
debt and hampered by excessive
regulations people would be you don't
want to see public money going to what
is a private enterprise that is somewhat
on the up they would like to see money
go to develop jobs that occurred but you
know there's only eight regular-season
games at home if you get in the playoffs
you get a few or the preseason games so
I would be cautious on spending heavy
public money on that even LaBonge
recognizes that financing a stadium with
taxpayer money may not be the most
responsible act of city government yet
he and his fellow council members voted
unanimously for a 1.2 billion dollar
stadium plan known as farmer's field
that would be funded with nearly 350
million in public bonds the proposed la
deal pales in comparison to the recent
sweetheart deals cut by Atlanta and
Minneapolis which gave the NFL over a
billion dollars of public subsidies to
build new facilities and because of how
the deals are structured the league not
the cities get the lion's share of the
revenue derived from the stadium and
concessions making it difficult for
taxpayers to recover their investment
Daniel Durbin the director of the
university of southern california's
institute of sports medians
piety explains well in theory the the
value that it brings to your city
financially in theory could could be so
it's so high that it replaces the costs
of doing business there although
California has been more than happy to
wheel out money for all sorts of
projects like the bullet ring that we
just keep putting money into and putting
money into in Los Angeles is the same
way that the city government tends to
put a lot of money into projects that
may or may not play out just the sheer
land costs of a stadium are horribly
exorbitant in Southern California but
beyond that you have the difficulty of
the environment in LA and Los Angeles
you don't have we haven't had a NFL team
since 1995 so it's almost twenty years
and you don't notice people really
crying about it a lot or worrying about
it a lot in Los Angeles we've got
beaches we've got Hollywood we've got
all sorts of it we've got Disneyland
we've got all sorts of things to do
during the winter we don't live and die
by the NFL so the Los Angeles really
doesn't need the NFL the irony is that
even if Los Angeles did manage to build
a stadium there's no reason to think the
NFL may bite through it all the league
has remained non-committal telling
reason we would like to return to the
Los Angeles area but only if it works
for the community and the NFL there is
no timeline but we continue to monitor
all stadium related developments in the
area as their reluctance may not be a
bad thing thanks to the expansion of
sports broadcast and the NFL's Byzantine
blackout rules having a franchise can
make it hard for loyal fans to even
watch their hometown team play we have a
team in Los Angeles and that team
doesn't sellout they can black it out in
Los Angeles which means that you very
often will lose games as a fan and for
fans that there's no payback to that in
the 80s and early 90s when Los Angeles
had two teams here that almost never
sold out the Raiders in the and the Rams
the the audience was losing games
consistently if I can be a fan of the
New England Patriots in Los Angeles if I
could be a fan of the Buffalo Bills in
Los Angeles and follow the team it's
certainly with with online and with all
of the cable broadcasts be being at
least accessible for me I can watch any
game that I want to if I
if I have the ingenuity and the money I
could be if I can be a fan of those
teams what does it pay me back to go to
a local Stadium in Los Angeles so in Los
Angeles you know if you look at it as a
fan you're the one who's chasing you
know if you if you really want an NFL
team here you're always chasing in that
relationship because the NFL isn't
concerned about you as a fan the NFL was
concerned about opening up your
pocketbook and pulling as much money out
of it as I possibly can while local
boosters like councilman LaBonge may
continue to dream of luring the NFL to
their city it's becoming increasingly
clear that not having a team may be the
best deal for taxpayers and fans alike
perhaps it's a model other cities should
emulate
[Music]